NPD我跟大家科普一下好不好？
我特意有一张图，
NPD非常有意思啊，
我特别喜欢研究NPD。
什么叫NPD？
它在心理学上叫做自恋型人格障碍，
NPD是它的缩写，
简写。
什么叫自恋型人格障碍呢？
它是一种心理疾病，
而且是一种整个心理咨询界都放弃的心理疾病。
为什么要放弃这样的心理疾病呢？
因为治不好。
从心理学产生到今天这些历史当中，
没有哪一个心理咨询师敢宣称自己曾经治愈过，
把那个NPP治好过没有，
这就是他很牛的地方。
然后他典型的特征是什么？
我挨个给你们数啊。
第一个典型的特征，
永远不会承认自己有错，
出现任何矛盾，
出现任何差池，
一定是你的原因，
就算他投资失败了，
就算他被炒鱿鱼了，
一定是你不带财呀，
你不问我呀，
他自己不会有任何错误的。
第二点，
爱撒谎，
张嘴就来，
而且他会篡改他自己的记忆，
他一定会说，
今天之所以产生这样的结果，
就是因为你不听我当时的劝，
就是因为当时我教你怎么怎么样，
你没有采纳我的意见，
才会导致今天的这个错误。
爱撒谎，
他会篡改自己的记忆，
总是把自己的记忆篡改成他是正确的，
他是伟光正的，
你是错误的，
你是卑微的，
你是特别那个啥的。
再有一个控制欲极强。
就是都得按他的那个路子来，
不按他的路子来的话，
那就比杀了他还难受。
还有就是嫉妒心超强，
他不会觉得别人优秀，
他只会觉得你是通过裙带关系，
你是通走过门，
你是通过牺牲色相，
你是通过干什么才爬到我头上去的，
你怎么可能比我优秀？
有一个不懂得感恩，
你帮他一次两次，
三次四次，
没有一次不帮他，
他就恨死你，
他不会记住你的恩心，
他只记仇不记恩，
他不会懂得感恩。
还有没有同情心，
没有同理心，
你都发烧都40°了，
在他看来的话，
你没死了起来给我做饭，
没有同情心，
没有同理心，
她不会感受到你怀孕把怀胎十月多么辛苦，
熬夜带孩子多么辛苦，
她觉得你应该的。
再有一个是什么喜欢贬低别人，
就老戳你的痛处，
老说你这不好，
老说你身材不好，
皮肤不好，
老说你是认知水平低，
他觉得他自己认知水平可高了，
还有什么？
他没有什么长期的朋友，
因为处时间长了，
大家都会发现，
总是贬低别人，
总是抬高自己，
总是嫉妒别人，
你对别人没有什么好处，
你也感受不到别人的痛苦，
你也不会安慰别人，
他没有长时间的朋友。
再有一个是什么呢？
他总会觉得他自己被亏欠了，
全世界都欠他的，
就算你帮他一次，
帮他两次，
帮他3次，
第4次你不帮他了，
你亏欠我的，
你凭什么不帮我？
还有一个是什么呢？
自我感觉良好，
他觉得他自己可帅了，
可漂亮了，
可优秀了，
那周围一个人啊，
能够跟他交朋友属于脸上。
富有，
光做他的女朋友，
那都是你祖坟上冒青烟，
他能让你给他做饭，
感谢吧，
我为什么不让别人给我做饭呢？
我瞧得上你，
我才让你给我做饭，
才让你伺候我，
我让你伺候我，
你贵谢隆恩，
这就是NPD。
还有呢，
喜欢花大饼，
花大饼是什么意思呢？
他说啊，
以后我有钱了，
我要给你买房，
他就觉得他已经是对你极好了，
你怎么不懂得感恩，
实际上他毛都没出，
实际上他屁都没干，
实际上你半毛钱利益你都没占着，
但他觉得他已经对你全世界，
他对你最好。
他说他有钱了，
他给你买车，
他有钱了，
他让你过好日子，
他有钱了他给你买金镯子，
全靠花大饼还有啥容易，
因为他需要普遍的认可，
他交朋友啊，
他不是为了说真心的去跟人交朋友，
他是需要周围的人都认可他，
都抬举他，
都吹他，
都碰他，
特别容易出，
你但凡有个人吹捧一下他，
他就觉得你对我有意思了，
你但凡跟他生活在一起长途中，
你不可能天天吹捧他吧，
你不可能天天抬着他吧，
他就对你没意思了，
特别容易吹他出轨了之后还说你为什么不大度啊，
你为什么不能像别的女人这么大度？